Sharks are going to starve to death!
And it’s all our fault!
Sorry, pal.
Hey everyone, I’m Chastity, the Associate
Producer for DNews.
Say what you want about climate change, but
the fact still remains that levels of carbon
dioxide are rising fast in our atmosphere.
And its causing major concerns for marine
life.
As the oceans absorb more CO2 from the air,
the waters become more acidic.
The latest report on greenhouse gases from
the World Meteorological Organization shows
carbon dioxide levels in the atmosphere rose
at an alarming rate last year, shattering
previous records.
And for the first time, the annual report
on greenhouse gases included figures on ocean
acidification.
The WMO says the rate of acidification is
now “unprecedented, at least over the past
300,000 years.”
If ocean acidification continues at its current
pace, a new study published in Global Change
Biology says that sharks could lose their
ability to sense the smell of food.
For the study, researchers from Georgia Tech
tested the odor-tracking behaviors of the
smooth dogfish, a shark native to the Atlantic
Ocean off the eastern United States.
They placed the dogfish in swimming pools
treated with carbon dioxide.
The CO2 concentrations tested matched the
projected climate forecasts for midcentury
and the year 2100.
Researchers found that the adult sharks significantly
avoided squid odor after swimming in the CO2
treated pools.
The sharks’ tracking and attacking behavior
were significantly reduced.
Sharks use other senses, like hearing, to
track prey, but none is more important than
chemical sensing.
Lead author of the study, Danielle Dixson,
says "Sharks are like swimming noses, so chemical
cues are really important for them in terms
of finding food."
In the past, sharks have adapted to ocean
acidification conditions projected for later
time periods.
But they’ve never had to adapt as quickly
as they do today.
Dixson says “It’s the rate of change that’s
happening that’s concerning.
Sharks have never had to deal with it this
fast.”
Previous research by Dixson and her team has
shown that fishes’ sensory systems are also
seriously affected by future CO2 concentrations
in the ocean.
Reef fish were less able to detect predator
odor when tested in water treated with projected
future CO2 concentrations.
The only problem with the research is that
it’s all laboratory based, so it doesn’t
fully represent the potential effects of future
ocean acidification.
Regardless, the rising CO2 concentrations
in our oceans is still a major problem for
future marine life.
If you wanna know more about climate change
realities and solutions, we’re gonna be
tackling those topics with Upworthy and other
special guests - and YOU get to take part
in the conversation!
So join us for our first Twitter Upchat this
Monday, September 15th, at 11am Eastern Time,
using the hashtag #UpChat.
And follow DNews and UpWorthy for more Climate
Change related content.
Thanks for watching!